good afternoon everyone
I am Shinya takahashi and I lead all
Nintendo software development Nintendo
switch has inherited DNA from each of
the many hardware systems Nintendo has
released today the Nintendo
Entertainment System included two
controllers in the base system Gameboy
made it possible to bring video games
out of the home Super NES added the x
and y buttons and the l and r buttons to
enhance the fun nintendo 64 offered the
world's first analog control stick and
it introduced a rumbling controller with
the development of the rumble Pak we put
a handle on Nintendo GameCube so it
could be carried around even at that
time we were considering a home game
system that you could take with you but
it seems we were a little too soon
Nintendo DS added a touch screen with
the Wii Remote motion control became
possible and the Wii U gamepad enabled
you to play games off the TV and now
Nintendo switch has inherited all of
Nintendo's entertainment DNA and we have
packed each and every one of these
features into the system Nintendo is
constantly pursuing new forms of
entertainment to bring more fun and more
smiles to the world and the new
entertainment we will present in 2017 is
Nintendo switch
[Music]
Nintendo 64 Nintendo switch is a video
game system for the home you connected
into the TV to play games
there'll be no mic on when you want to
play away from the TV in both seats you
just remove Nintendo switch from the
dock when you attach the left and right
joint on controllers you can continue
playing anywhere
Nintendo switch has been designed to be
a home console gaming system gives you
the freedom is to change your play style
[Music]
next allow me to introduce the play
styles Nintendo switch will offer model
TV mode play games on the TV and typical
video game style tabletop mode sweetie
stand the Nintendo switch console up
with its kickstand and play using the
toy con you can now play video games in
front of a screen with others wherever
you like
even away from the TV handheld mode [ __ ]
you know it ghouls attach the left and
right joy Kong to the system kunai demo
you can take it with you and play
indoors outdoors or anywhere you like
house of beyond what do you think of
handing a joy con to a friend or family
members and sharing the joy right then
in there
makino tsukushi car battery life will
vary by game in you but it will range
from two and a half hours to six and a
half hours dingos you can USB pen you
will be able to play while charging the
system using the included AC adapter in
the US be certified portable batteries
coming the screen uses a capacitive
touch panel my niece is Lucas date you
can connect over Wi-Fi for multiplayer
battles site dock they in doctor 18
Nintendo switch systems can be connected
for local wireless multiplayer gaming
[Music]
what do you think with its three play
styles Nintendo switch evolves gameplay
making it more active and offering
greater freedom of play
[Music]